À 8 heures, on attendait toujours,
car il arrive souvent que les hommes politiques soient en retard,
d'une heure ou plus.
Une fois 8 heures passées, on est parti à vélo chez ces hommes politiques,
pour leur rappeler le repas.
La femme d'un homme politique m'a dit :
« Désolée, il souffre de maux de tête, il ne peut pas venir. »
Je suis allé chez un autre
et sa femme m'a rassuré : « Partez, il vous rejoindra. »
J'étais confiant que le repas allait avoir lieu comme prévu,
même s'il n'était pas à grande échelle.
Je suis retourné sur place, dans un nouveau parc dédié au mahatma Gandhi.
Il était 10 heures.
Aucun des hommes politiques n'est venu.
Ce qui m'a rendu furieux.
J'étais debout, adossé à un statue du mahatma Gandhi,
épuisé au plan émotionnel, et fatigué.
Puis, je me suis mis à table.
J'ai maîtrisé mes émotions.
Mais dès que j'ai pris la première bouchée,
j'ai fondu en larmes.
Tout d'un coup, j'ai senti une main sur mon épaule.
C'était le contact apaisant, maternel d'une femme intouchable.
Elle m'a dit : « Kailash, pourquoi pleures-tu ?
Tu as fais ta part.
Tu as mangé de la nourriture préparée par les intouchables,
ce qui n'est jamais arrivé aussi loin qu'on s'en souvienne. »
Elle a ajouté : « Aujourd'hui, tu as gagné. »
Mes amis, elle a eu raison.
Peu après minuit, je suis rentré chez moi.
J'ai été choqué de voir que de nombreux aînés de haute caste
étaient assis chez moi, dans la cour.
Ma mère et des femmes âgées pleuraient,
elles suppliaient ces aînés
car ils avaient menacé d'ostraciser toute ma famille.
Vous savez, pour une famille, la sanction sociale la plus pénible
est d'être ostracisé.
Finalement, ils se sont mis d'accord pour ne punir que moi. J'ai dû me purifier.
Pour cela, je devais faire un voyage à environ 1 000 kilomètres de chez moi,
pour prendre un bain sacré dans les eaux du Gange.
Ensuite, je devais organiser un repas de fête pour 101 religieux,
laver leurs pieds et boire cette eau.
C'était n'importe quoi,
et j'ai refusé d'accepter cette punition.
Alors qu'ont-ils fait pour me punir ?
On m'a interdit d'entrer dans ma cuisine et dans ma salle à manger,
mes couverts ont été mis à part.
Cette nuit-là quand j'étais en colère, ils voulaient m'ostraciser.
Mais moi, j'ai décidé d'ostraciser le système de castes dans son ensemble.
(Applaudissements)
C'était possible. Pour commencer,
il fallait changer de nom de famille, de patronyme,
car en Inde, la plupart des noms de famille sont des appellations de caste.
J'ai donc décidé d'abandonner mon nom de famille.
Puis je me suis donné un nouveau nom : Satyarthi,
qui signifie « celui qui cherche la vérité ».
(Applaudissements)
C'était le début de ma colère au pouvoir transformateur.
Mes amis, peut-être l'un de vous le sait déjà,
qu'est-ce que je faisais avant de militer pour les droits des enfants ?
Quelqu'un le sait peut-être ?
Non.
J'étais ingénieur, ingénieur électricien.
J'ai donc appris comment l'enérgie
produite par le feu qui brûle, par le charbon,
par l'explosion nucléaire dans une chambre de combustion,
par les courants rapides du fleuve,
par les vents violents
peut être transformée en lumière pour améliorer la vie de millions de gens.
J'ai également appris comment l’énergie, sous sa forme non maîtrisée,
peut être exploitée pour le bien-être de la société.
Je reviens maintenant à l'histoire de mon séjour en prison :
Je me sentais heureux d'avoir sauvé une douzaine d'enfants de l'esclavage,
et de les avoir remis à leurs parents.
Ma joie quand je réussi à sauver un enfant est indicible.
Je me sentais si heureux.
Mais alors que j’attendais le train pour rentrer chez moi à Delhi,
j'ai remarqué des douzaines d'enfants qui arrivaient,
victimes de la traite.
J'ai arrêté les trafiquants.
Je me suis plaint auprès de la police.
Au lieu de m'aider, les policiers
m'ont arrêté et m'ont enfermé dans une petite cellule, comme un animal.
Cette nuit de colère
a fait naître une des plus belles idées.
Je me suis dis que si je sauve 10 enfants et 50 autres prennent leur place,
cela va continuer sans fin.
J'ai eu confiance dans le pouvoir des consommateurs,
et je vous assure que c'est la première fois
qu'on a lancé une telle campagne dans le monde,
visant à éduquer et à sensibiliser les consommateurs
afin de créer la demande pour des tapis qui ne sont pas fabriqués par les enfants.
On a réussi à le faire en Europe et en Amérique.
Cela a eu pour résultat de réduire le travail des enfants
de 80% dans les pays d'Asie du Sud.
(Applaudissements)
Ce n'est pas tout : cette toute première campagne menée par les consommateurs
s'est répandue dans d'autres pays et d'autres industries,
qu'il s'agisse de la fabrication du chocolat, des vêtements ou des chaussures.
Ma colère à l'âge de 11 ans,
lorsque j'ai compris à quel point il importait d'éduquer chaque enfant,
a donné naissance à l'idée de faire la collecte de livres d'occasion
pour aider les enfants les plus pauvres.
J'ai créé une « banque de livres » à l'âge de 11 ans.
Et je ne me suis pas arrêté là.
Plus tard, j'ai cofondé la campagne
la plus importante de la société civile en faveur de l'éducation dans le monde,
qui est la Campagne mondiale pour l'éducation.
Celle-ci a amené un changement de perspective en matière d'éducation :
on est passé de la charité aux droits de l'Homme,
ce qui a divisé par deux le nombre d'enfants non scolarisés
au cours des 15 dernières années.
(Applaudissements)
La colère que j'ai éprouvé à l'âge de 27 ans m'a poussé à sauver
la fille qui était sur le point d'être vendue à une maison de prostitution.
D'où m'est venu l'idée de poursuivre
une nouvelle stratégie d'opération de secours
pour sauver les enfants de l'esclavage.
Je suis fier qu'on a eu la chance de sauver non pas 1, 10 ou 20 enfants esclaves
mais mes collègues et moi-même avons pu en libérer 83 000 physiquement
et les rendre à leurs parents et à leurs mères.
(Applaudissements)
Je savais qu'on avait besoin de politiques mondiales.
On a organisé des marches partout dans le monde contre le travail des enfants
qui ont abouti à une nouvelle convention internationale
visant à protéger les enfants qui vivent dans les pires conditions.
Le résultat concret est que le nombre des enfants travailleurs dans le monde
a été réduit d'un tiers au cours des 15 dernières années.
(Applaudissements)
Dans chaque cas,
tout a commencé par la colère,
qui s'est transformée en une idée
et ensuite en action.
Donc pour résumer, la colère, et quoi ensuite ?
L'idée, et --
Public : L'action
Kailash Satyarthi : La colère, l'idée, l'action. C'est ce que j'essaie de faire.
La colère est une force, une énergie,
et selon la loi de la nature, il est impossible
de créer ou de détruire l’énergie. Elle ne disparaît jamais.
Pourquoi ne pas exploiter et transformer la force de la colère
pour créer un magnifique monde meilleur, un monde plus juste et plus équitable ?
La colère existe en chacun de vous,
et je partage avec vous un secret :
si on reste confiné dans les limites étroites de notre ego,
et dans notre égoïsme,
cette colère se manifeste par la haine, la violence, la vengeance et la destruction.
Mais si on réussit à briser ce cercle vicieux,
cette colère peut se transformer en un pouvoir très puissant.
Grâce à la compassion qui existe en nous, on peut briser ces cercles
pour communiquer l'un avec l'autre avec compassion pour rendre le monde meilleur.
La colère peut se transformer en compassion.
Mes chers amis, mes frères et sœurs, en tant que lauréat du prix Nobel,
je répète, je vous encourage à vous mettre en colère.
Je vous encourage à vous mettre en colère.
La personne la plus fâchée parmi nous
est celle qui peut transformer sa colère en idées et ensuite, en actions.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson : Depuis des années, vous inspirez les autres.
Mais qui vous inspire, ou quoi, et pourquoi ?
KS : C'est une bonne question.
Chris, je vous dis la vérité
chaque fois lorsque je réussis à sauver un enfant,
un enfant qui a perdu l'espoir de pouvoir revoir sa mère,
son sourire au moment de sa mise en liberté,
et la mère qui a perdu l'espoir qu'un jour
elle puisse prendre sur ses genoux, son fils ou sa fille,
leur émotion est telle que
la première larme de joie qui coule sur sa joue,
j'y vois un aperçu de Dieu -- c'est ma plus grande inspiration.
J'ai tellement de chance, comme je l'ai déjà dit, de voir des milliers de fois
mon Dieu sur les visages de ces enfants
qui m'inspirent le plus.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)